ejemplo land muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 bueno como
decíamos lamentablemente una vez más el
accionar de la policía está en el centro
de la polémica no organizaciones
sociales aseguran haber recibido
denuncias por lo menos de decenas de
personas que habrían sido asesinadas por
disparos de las fuerzas policiales desde
temblores la ong de la que usted hace
parte maneja en algún tipo de
información de este tipo
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
si nosotros tenemos que decir en primer
lugar que nuestra plataforma grita que
es a través de donde nosotros recibimos
todos los reportes de violencia policial
hemos tenido un reporte de 940 casos de
violencia policial desde que arrancaron
las jornadas dentro de estos 940 casos
tenemos el registro de 12 víctimas de
agresión en el ojo 92 víctimas de
violencia física por parte de la policía
21 víctimas de violencia homicida por
parte de la fuerza pública en el marco
de las movilizaciones 672 casos de
detenciones arbitrarias en contra de los
manifestantes y 133 intervenciones
violentas por parte de la fuerza pública
en donde el esmad gaztea y dispersas
las movilizaciones pacíficas como luego
a usted en general ya que atribuye este
tipo de accionar de las fuerzas de
seguridad colombianas
bueno en primer lugar esto se da en el
marco de un fallo judicial el día antes
de las protestas en colombia en donde el
tribunal de cundinamarca le da la orden
a los alcaldes y gobernadores de que
suspendan las movilizaciones este fallo
por un lado generó dos cosas que la
gente saliera con mucha más rabia
protestar se en el espacio público y que
las fuerzas policiales estuvieran
legitimados para ejercer violencia
contra quienes salían a movilizarse y
eso lo vimos con una intensidad que se
ha venido un incremento desde que se
publica un tuit del expresidente álvaro
uribe vélez en donde dice que la fuerza
pública está en un legítimo derecho de
disparar a los manifestantes para
proteger su vida y en ese sentido
nosotros desde el día de antier hemos
venido documentando en nuestra
plataforma un incremento de todos los
casos de violencia policial y el día de
mañana 3 vamos a entregar alas a la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos un reporte completo con nuestra
base de datos de todos estos casos
porque no existen garantías judiciales
aquí en colombia para garantizar el
acceso a la justicia de quienes han sido
víctimas de violencia homicida y de
violencia física